You don't know me.
How do you know what I'm about
to say is something you can trust?
It's actually your responsibility to make
sure that your information is authentic.
This is where data literacy comes in.
It can help you evaluate the reliability of news sources.
Make informed decisions about your health and finances.
Even protect you from scams and misinformation.
In schooling, data literacy can help you understand
and analyze complex information in subjects like math and science.
And in the business world,
a culture of data literacy means
everyone in the organization can make better data-driven decisions.
Plus, it's a valuable skill that can open up career
opportunities in fields like data science and market research.
So don't just consume your data at face value.
To learn more about all things data,
head on over to the Data Differentiator,
IBM's guide for data leaders and enthusiasts alike.
We hope to see you there.